[Music]
twelve times that you are dealing with a
master manipulator you know what there's
12 five signs and astrological calendar
tests so there's 12 zodiac line ass
[ __ ]
there's also 12 eggs in a dozen and 12
what's in the calendar
oh you're right okay so there's this new
study on this kind of it rates this
trait called
machiavellianism Makaveli
that's the only thing I know about magic
belly so the new study can help you spot
manipulation do you know okay so
Makaveli he wrote the book called the
prudent italian philosopher and he wrote
this basically the theory is for
princess Prince Royals and people who
want to maintain and sustain power but
it's made for Nobles or a pit pushovers
so they're teaching people how to be a
little bit crazy cuz his theory is the
bad guys always win not the nice guys
the bad guys who don't play by the rules
they win because people who play by the
rules in politics and war and all that
stuff what ends up happening is their
goodness is exploited Wow bad people
they don't give a [ __ ] because don't
break lie steal cheat whatever they
[ __ ] have to to win Ned Stark that's
why you guys also uh Tupac called them
self Machiavelli because he studied
Machiavelli in prison mark of death and
a lot of people think that POC faked his
death because Machiavelli wrote about
how the only way to escape your enemies
is to fake your own death right do you
think you think I think Pakistani hippie
I do I do I do
no memes no memes oh no me miss way good
for you
do you think Neil Armstrong is really
dead yeah I know I think the real person
that isn't dead is Elvis yeah why when
you think it was dead on I did I sorry
Elvis is not dead I think Michael
Jackson's not dead I think my projection
is not dead pre dead
[Music]
I don't think is that he's pretty good I
don't think I don't think much let's get
back to Mecca million no I think the
Michael Jackson still doing his thing
which is wise oh it's a children please
let's talk about this let me give you a
definition Mac wait what is it Bank
attacks to do other than touch children
that walk past even women Paul Green
Machiavelli ISM is a set psychological
trait centered on interpersonal
manipulation unemotional coldness and
indifference to morality damn that
sounds twisted as but yeah Machiavellian
there's three ugly traits I think that
people yes there's cycle path
there's Machiavellian and then there's
narcissism really okay yeah so it's
narcissism Machiavellianism and
psychopath psychopath II sigh coffee
okay so everyone can take this test dark
I'll tear it Tyra yeah it's it and you
can see which ones you lean more towards
well tell you right to tell us please
I'm just gonna show you Joey and TJ
debaters listen I I don't know what I am
okay I'm a Capricorn you know well I'm
lovin there's a 12 item scale that
divides into two components and views
and tactics okay I will show you the
first order tell you the first one so
this is the scale number one in my
opinion human nature is to be dishonest
yeah
number two I it's relative okay out of
these six okay listen
and these six things that I'm about to
say pick out which one you like like you
fall into the looks okay I said the
first one number two I think that most
people will take advantage of others in
the right situation no number three when
people do something nice for me they
really have another agenda no yeah or
wow I feel that deep down people trust
each other yeah kind of number five I
think people would rather help each
other than act selfishly
yes number six I believe that most
people are essentially good yes that's
me
I'm mostly talking about Americans I
think six are the efficient yes out of
these okay okay so you're six what are
you I'm a six I think I'm going for two
- what do you I am six but everyone is
doing they're good they're good what
that means is even if you're a gang
member
yeah you're doing committing crime
you're doing you're good yeah yes that's
why it's relative to my Wayne I don't I
don't really know everyone's fighting
their own fight is what I'm saying I'm
with it but there Nate Lee doing it for
a good reason
cuz it's good in their mind yes I'm
saying yes generally what's - again I
think that most people will take
advantage of others in the right
situation Tim is shady as [ __ ] the
reality is you're right like more
towards Machiavelli in a zonal yeah
because I believe that people will steal
with the right opportunity without they
would justify their thievery and they
wouldn't even realize that they're
stealing maybe that makes sense to me
playing the eldest old game did when I
play an Elder Scrolls game I'm still a
cheat like a mobile yeah [ __ ] yeah so
now this is on this is the views
subscale okay so now you guys all know
where you you stand I were to ice the
hectic Oh
the last three were like the good traits
and then the top three are like the bad
traits of Machiavelli oh yeah oh you
know Tim shady keep doing okay know that
what you know people you've seen some
[ __ ] people are good and people are bad
and that's just kind of part of who we
are I thought the manager of the
Backstreet Boys whose shirt you're
wearing right now do you think you hey
thank get a break what about the manager
of NSYNC who is also okay he's the same
guy Lou Pearlman yeah
so what'd you what'd you think of him
thank you to the manage of these boys
inside here I want to know here we got
black subscale number one I think that
it is okay to be unethical for the
greater good no number two I think that
it is okay to take advantage of others
to achieve an important goal no number
three it is sometimes necessary for me
to mislead others to get things done
those first didn't make me horny
so you agree with those first three
times kinky number four I value being
honest over getting ahead yes number
five to me it is never justified to
deceive others number six to me
something is not worth doing if it
requires being unethical yeah I think
I'm number four was for again he just
threw a number out
I value being honest over getting ahead
yeah it's like I want to rob houses
sometimes what solution was that
no I'm number four is number one I think
it's okay to be an ethical for them you
know I like number four or actually it
could be number two I think it's okay to
take advantage of others to achieve an
emergency number one and to never before
I think that's like a three on that it
is sometimes necessary for me to mislead
others to get things done yeah cuz I
think about but you man think about
emails I've sent to brands to give my
brand deals and I'm like I've said
things uh just to convince them that I'd
be good for their brand even though I
know it's not yeah you know what
actually I think you're more effective
for their brand than you give yourself
credit for
Oh deep down you're telling the truth
people know most people do this they
don't recognize the power that they
bring to some brand but genuinely you
have to realize that sometimes you can't
scroll up to get the [ __ ] actual
number of what you impacted sometimes
it's a repetition game right like so
like oh like me and Bart and Joe we all
advertise the same thing on the same day
well maybe my post didn't reach them but
maybe Joe's didn't didn't reach them but
maybe by the third time Bart's did it
close a deal and then they don't see
mine or Joe's when they look at the
analytics to see my link right or
sometimes it's not either of us all
three of us it's they go well I don't
want to open it in [ __ ] at the iPhone
because it goes with Safari and I hate
Safari and so they go to their own phone
they open it up there and that's where
it's effective so this idea that like we
can analyze where it all came from is
[ __ ]
so I think you're more effective for
brands do you think um no I'm just
saying I've definitely told brands that
I like that whose food I didn't like
that I liked so I could get a check to
do a video that's just as honest yeah
that's her
now that you're admitting it oh yeah all
right Joe where do you think the brand I
sure hope we didn't promote them at the
foodies tactics of the scale wait you're
not in fremantle anyway in any I agree
with all this [ __ ] you got a pick one
where do you fall what's the one you
agree with the most number [ __ ] one
here eat slow you're number one number
one
so you're the closest to
machiavellianism the the better the
worst race so far that's on Brad it's
wrong what they're saying here to be on
number one is to be unethical for the
greater good I will take a [ __ ] dick
for all of you why is that unethical Joe
a small Decker in my line help to
understand that it is would you take a
small dick or a big dick for all of us
anything for you guys really crazy man
you said anything we talking mouth or
bow is it anything the more painful it
is the more indebted you will be to me
they're saying that people that were
scoring higher yeah that they are more
likely to have misanthropic views
towards others and to be highly
narcissistic and to have lower
well-being wait wait didn't means that
oh right both the highest one everyone
what a score what score higher means you
pick the first ones pick the last but
the last one by sixes and sixes I think
so I don't know yeah yeah it's probably
not rated by number that's some weight
that's some wack-ass [ __ ] to say like
psychologically we can break you by one
out of six
well no it's - it's a two parter so one
out of six for the views and 1 out of 6
for tactics and then seeing where you
fall listen IQ tests aren't even 12
questions so like what the [ __ ] yeah
they're generally speaking so they're
pretty much going what do you want in a
two piece combo I know who you are
here's I think the reason why these self
assess surveys do not [ __ ] work is
because people have something called an
ego that
then from seeing who they really are so
they go oh I'm a wonderful person yes do
you think we know the answer at the end
dictators don't [ __ ] go around the
world saying I'm doing evil do Kim Jong
Un's like I'm killing it brother I'm so
honest and ethical I'm so they're like
look at all the wonderful [ __ ] I'm doing
so you should want to do for my people
like like there's like three of them
who'd love me so you got to get someone
else to rate you yeah but it depends on
preservative yeah it completely depends
on perspective I got to read this
Machiavelli book it's cool it's called
the prince oh I have that I just never
read it yeah I mean but it's never it's
really one of the first books or the one
of the books that's survived throughout
time that a lot of leaders and
politicians and people that have to
maneuver through social situations they
learn this book because you know it just
teaches people how to be socially
manipulative ooh which one was it
was it that not 48 laws of power no I
got the auto audio book it's insane
and I hated every minute of it unlike
you I'm friends with the author like
you're viewing the world from the most
like ugliest like I felt so disgusted
listening to that way why why is it I
didn't like it because they were saying
like every single person in your life is
an [ __ ] out to get you and I don't
get that from the book that's what I got
this test is saying cuz me and gos it's
a very reasonable [ __ ] and then I go if
you scored high your piece of [ __ ] I'm
like maybe I didn't read the right okay
yeah cuz I had that book and I study I
love what he loves of power that's the
one I was like amazing I didn't like it
and I and I like his recent book it's
called laws of human nature I like that
it's the same offer I like novels of
power okay here's the thing about that
book it's not meant for everyone because
Clues really about me you got to look at
it from an outside perspective of the
dynamics of power in human nature like
why do p.m. question
want to come after you if you have the
most power right and in so you're in a
world where we're people you it powerful
places it attracts or interesting
characters so how do you maneuver in
that dangerous world okay yeah that's
different because for me the way I was
receiving I literally only listen to
like five or ten minutes I don't even
give it a chance cuz immediately I was
like I hate this [ __ ] so there was like
everyone in the world is out to get
their power
I'll let me put it this way though you
also hate mafia I do I mean you don't
understand that's that world it's
different yeah
I'm like keep me out of it yeah Basia
turns me on sexually
[Music]
[Music]